I'm Abby hornacek I'm Ben Dominic I'm
Dana Perino and this is the Fox News
Rundown
[Music]
Friday December 2nd 2022 I'm Chris
Foster Democrats rally around our new
leader in the house some conservative
Republicans are divided about Kevin
McCarthy becoming house speaker in
January they think he's not responsive
to their agenda to their concerns they
want a seat at the table and they're
continually you know publicly there are
microphones and cameras all over Capitol
Hill and they continue to find them and
say he doesn't have our votes to become
speaker we're speaking with Fox News
Sunday host Shannon Breen and Lisa Brady
mentally ill and homeless so potentially
dangerous combination that New York is
hoping to address but could the new plan
test legal limits I think there is
generally an acceptance of the idea that
some people with untreated serious
mental illness are gonna need some sort
of involuntary treatment and I'm Tom
shallou I've got the final word on the
Fox News Rundown
foreign
Congressman Kevin McCarthy has been a
member of the House Republican
leadership since 2009 the leader since
2019 with an eye on becoming house
speaker and Republicans take control in
January he needs 218 votes in a full
house vote and it's expected to be a
fight all the work that we want to do
from rolling out the investigations from
rebuilding our economy from securing our
border none of that can go forward
without us moving forward on the floor
having the vote of the speaker putting
the rules in and working together as one
leader McCarthy on Fox on the other side
of the aisle New York Congressman Hakeem
Jeffries with no challenge in the end is
the Democrats new house leader it's an
honor to stand before you today as the
incoming house democratic leader
for the 118th Congress he has the job
held by Nancy Pelosi for 20 years folks
on the right will say he's extreme he's
so far partisan so far left but you've
got the progressives where he's really
pushed back against the squad in the
past now they're having conversations
about how they can work together Shannon
bream's the host of Fox News Sunday but
the progressives have been worried that
he wouldn't be open to their position so
we know these had meetings with folks
like congresswoman jayapal and that
they're you know trying to find ways
that they can work together but he's
done some pushback of the progressives
he's helped some of the Democrats who
were being challenged some of the
incumbents by some of these Progressive
up-and-comers trying to come into their
primaries so you know like any leader of
the party he's going to have to manage
all of those different factions but it
sounds like he's having conversations
with them and people think he's got a
lot of strong leadership qualities and
will be able to step in this role and
just hit the ground running yeah I mean
20 years that job has been taken by
Nancy Pelosi and now suddenly Jeffries
by file appearances now was just sort of
anointed but we also know that behind
the scenes it's been you know whatever a
year two years three years that this has
been bubbling up or he's been building a
coalition of people and uh and and the
Democrats number two and three now are
Catherine Clark of Massachusetts pet
Aguilar of California and they've just
sort of quietly banded together to rise
to these positions and become a new
youngest generation yeah and uh we
always chuckle that when we're talking
about youngish women people like in
their 50s which makes me feel good that
that's but that's Capitol Hill when
you've got leaders who are in their 80s
50s is youngish and there's been
pressure as we've talked about many
times within the Democrat Party
um to have that next bench of leadership
to give them a chance to to step up to
the plate and get things done and Usher
in the new generation of leaders so you
know Congressman Jeffries was very much
had the as you say kind of the anointing
had the stamp the seal of approval from
those outgoing leaders from speaker
Pelosi from cine Hoyer and from James
Clyburn who was fighting to stay in in
leadership as one of the older members
of that generation so he's got a lot of
people who are on his side and as you
said it takes a lot of behind the scenes
um work of building those coalitions and
getting members on your side and and
proving to them that you're going to be
the leader who can move them forward and
he's been very skillful at that so he's
got the stamp of the Old Guard and now
clearly has uh the seal of approval from
the Next Generation as well yeah so
he'll be the minority leader he'd like
to be a house speaker in 2024 we'll see
how that shakes out the Republicans on
the other side of the aisle their leader
Kevin McCarthy
um he would like to be Speaker of the
House in January he had this aborted
attempt at becoming speaker in 2015 it
kind of fell apart and now he's he's
doing with some opposition now what's
going on why isn't he 100 being rallied
around yeah and I think it's the same
issue that Hakeem Jeffries has got with
the progressive caucus Kevin McCarthy's
got it with the house Freedom caucus the
folks that are further to the right over
in the house more conservative they
think he's not responsive to their
agenda to their concerns they want to
see it at the table and they're
continually you know publicly there are
microphones and cameras all over Capitol
Hill and they continue to find them and
say he doesn't have our votes to become
speaker and this gets really tricky
because then you've got some factions
out there saying like well maybe we'll
just go with the moderate choice or go
with someone that we can get some
democrat votes to pull us together
McCarthy's made very clear he will not
Lobby for and he does not want Democrats
votes he wants all the Republicans
voting for him but Congressman Annie
Biggs who is one of the more
conservative members says he thinks
there are a significant number I think
he said 20 that he thinks are not going
to vote for Kevin McCarthy that would be
a problem for him given how close this
margin is going to be for Republicans so
he's doing the same thing that you see
Congressman Jeffries doing he's over
there having conversations trying to
reassure these people and bring this
Coalition together but he's got some
really conservative members who say they
will not vote for him under any scenario
and that could be a problem well that
was my question is that is this just a
protest whole his feet to the Fire vote
and in the end they will
they will vote for McCarthy speaker
because I don't know how the
machinations work if if he cannot get
those 218 what happens
yeah they continue to go to additional
votes and ballots until they get some
kind of consensus so listen as much as
they've publicly said we're not going to
vote for him I don't know how he changes
their minds because they're going to
have to Pivot or he's going to have to
Pivot so whether they then get into the
nitty-gritty and realize you know it's
better to get half a loaf of bread than
no bread I think it was President Reagan
who kind of gave that analogy so they're
going to have some tough decisions to
make and I gotta think it's in their
interest to go with someone who will at
least listen to what they have to say
versus a candidate who's going to shut
them out completely and um you know Chad
pergram who was our excellent resident
expert on everything on Capitol Hill has
told us about scenarios in which votes
went on for days and weeks until this
the speaker situation was settled so who
knows if we're about to go down that
path again looking ahead to early 2024
there's a Democratic National Committee
uh meeting happening that could shake up
the primary calendar it's been Iowa and
New Hampshire for seemingly the
beginning of time and some people think
it's time to move on from those States
as being too white too old maybe let's
start with some place like Nevada maybe
maybe Minnesota or someplace else
um it would be really strange to not
start with Iowa New Hampshire yes and
think about all the Iowa t-shirts we've
all gotten over the years you go there
and then people know you're going to
descend there for the caucuses I mean
this is if you're a wonky political nerd
as I will call myself you can classify
it as you like but we like this stuff
the inside stuff this to me is
fascinating because then you have
threats that okay by some leaders if
it's if the Republican and Democrat
caucuses aren't on the same weekend in
Iowa then we're going to move our
caucuses to you know Halloween to the
October before that so that I mean the
threats that are getting thrown around
are interesting but remember what Iowa
you know this is just before covet
really blew up and we kind of came off
the political Trail what happened in
Iowa was so strange the caucus was never
really settled for Democrats about what
happened there and who actually won
still questions about how that whole
vote went down so Iowa did not make a
good case for itself with Democrats in
2020 it'll be very interesting to me to
see and I think the president has got a
lot of sway over what happens here and
and if he makes any pronouncements on
how this thing goes down I think he's
going to have a lot of power to help set
this calendar and of course he's going
to want to do that in a way that's most
advantageous for him and for his party
in case he doesn't run but gosh I love
this inside baseball stuff with these
parties fighting internally and with
each other about who gets to go first in
the nation it will be a big change if
Iowa is not number one yeah there are
going to be a lot of Diner owners in
Iowa that are going to miss out on some
Revenue they count on every four years
um exactly Georgia Senate runoffs in a
few days there's been strong early
voting Herschel Walker the Republicans
had to deal with questions about you
know maybe paying for abortions and
questions about does he really live in
Texas his supporters I assume just like
how he's fighting through these
headwinds but some Republicans might
just not show up rather than vote for
him or the Democrat Rafael Warnock
yet and what a nightmare Georgia has
been for Republicans when you think
about these you know Senate seats the
two that were up after the 2020 election
and how that whole thing went down and
now they're off in this runoff again and
I think if the Senate was hanging the
balance you know if this is a situation
where
um Republicans had a chance to flip the
Senate I think there'd be a lot more
energy obviously behind Herschel Walker
but given that we know Senate Democrats
are going to control the chamber by
virtue of having the vice president as
their tie-breaking vote I think there's
a lot less excitement and heat generated
on the GOP side of the ticket yeah I was
I was shocked to hear from George's
lieutenant governor Jeff Duncan he's a
republican he says he waited in line to
vote in this runoff and he got there and
he looked at the ballot and said never
mind and walked out and didn't and just
didn't vote right and you got to think
um you know for him to even say that
publicly kind of disastrous for
Republicans but listen the governor
kampu had a sizable easy victory over
Stacy Abrams is out there campaigning
with Herschel Walker a lot of people
think camping on the ticket and the love
for him and his popularity actually
pulled Herschel Walker up far enough to
get into this runoff whether it's going
to be enough here like I said I think if
the Senate hanging in the balance was
still an issue it would be much better
for Herschel Walker but I just think
that there's going to be a lack of
enthusiasm on the GOP side of the ticket
and there you know in Georgia there is
weariness this has gone on and been so
ugly for months I do think a lot of
people are sort of checked out they're
on to Christmas in in Hanukkah and
Kwanzaa and the joyful holiday season
they're done with politics vice
president Pence you're going to talk to
him on Sunday right we are and um I
found some fascinating things in his new
book and he's very detailed about what
went down on January 6 and leading up to
that all of the disagreements he had
with the president about whether or not
he had the power to do anything on the
floor when he was overseeing the
counting of the electoral votes and gosh
there is some real you know he broke
with the president and there was some I
don't know if we want to call it bad
blood but definite attention and issues
there about the conversations he was
having privately with the president
trying to tell him his hands were tied
and he had a ceremonial constitutional
duty to go there to vet the objections
to these but ultimately he had no power
over changing the Electoral account Vote
or refusing to accept those votes even
getting so bad as to the point as the
night before there was a New York Times
piece that came out that said that Pence
had said to Trump I can't do this I'm
not going to do this and there was a
piece that New York Times piece that the
Trump campaign responded to and said
it's fake news Pence and the president
are on the same page Pence knew that was
a lie and at that point was so Furious
he just walked into January 6 knowing
what he had to do and what he's going to
do and the inside scoop about what went
down with the Secret Service and
everything that happened that day is
really fascinating but he was getting
tons of criticism yes he acted admirably
that day even as critics will say but
they're saying that he enabled the
president for four years up to that
point so that it was this ugly a bad day
for the country so I'll ask him about
that criticism and he's got some
interesting inside stories on the
Supreme Court too and since that's my
beat
um I was really interested by those
nuggets and we'll talk about that as
well very good um finishing up soccer
you've been watching I know you're a
very busy person uh you've been dead but
it's cool the games are on during the
day you've been you know trying to sneak
a little bit in here and there you a fan
uh well I will say I am married to a Die
Hard soccer fan so he keeps me up to
date um I thought World Cup was like
okay maybe a game or two for
Thanksgiving I didn't know it was like
four games a day I don't even supposed
to call them games matches I don't know
um but for days so yes we are all in in
this household Team USA go win on
Saturday she had a pretty most of Fox
News Sunday thanks good to talk to you
you too
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
with your Fox News commentary coming up
America's largest city launches a new
plan to deal with part of the homeless
population allowing police and other
city workers to hospitalize people
involuntarily if they're deemed to be
showing signs of mental illness and
posing a risk to themselves even if
they're not posing a risk of harm to
others for too long there's been a gray
area where policy law and accountability
have not been clear and this has allowed
people in need to slip through the
cracks mayor Eric Adams says the city
will still do all it can to persuade
those in need of help to accept Services
voluntarily but we would not abandon
them if those efforts cannot overcome
the person's unawareness of their own
illness he says they'll also push for
change at the state level but this is
partly an effort to use existing law the
mayor says it's a myth that someone has
to be violent suicidal or presenting a
risk of imminent harm for involuntary
assistance to be given and the new
policy confirms that posing a risk of
harm through an inability to meet basic
needs is part of the standard for mental
health interventions but Adams is facing
strong pushback the Coalition for the
homeless says he continues to get it
wrong that he relies on ineffective
strategies and scapegoats homeless
people and others with mental illness as
violent the group also says he's
ignoring issues with voluntary access to
psychiatric care and the New York civil
liberties Union is already suggesting
the plan May violate constitutional
limits well mayor Adams thinks that he
has the legal Authority already to
implement this plan to a degree Stephen
IDE is a senior fellow at the Manhattan
Institute and author of homelessness in
America that is to direct Frontline
providers police that they can start
abiding by this new standard for civil
commitment but he's also pushing for a
number of legal changes at the state law
law the state government is a huge
player in mental health so ultimately
the success of this plan does depend a
lot on Albany
there's a lot in play here in terms of
if police encounter a homeless person
you know they first have to decide does
this person pose a threat to themselves
there's some enhanced training involved
there's even a hotline they could call
to sort of get advice on this during an
encounter but it seems pretty subjective
I mean is is the is the nature of the
decision-making progress something that
could ultimately cause a problem
well uh I think there is generally an
acceptance of the idea that some people
with untreated serious mental illness
are going to need some sort of
involuntary treatment meaning probably
involuntary hospitalization in some
cases we used to do a lot of that
decades past we began doing less and
less over the years in hopes that we
were building a better public Mental
Health Care System but that cohort never
went away
and so what he's saying is that that
cohort is actually larger than we're
giving it credit for more people need
involuntary treatment than are getting
it now so we need to look for a way to
expand access to hospitalization and to
do that we need to examine the legal
standard that determines when we
intervene with somebody when they say no
no I don't want any Services because
sometimes we know that we really can
help someone even if they insist that
they want to remain right there on the
street
mm-hmm the jury's kind of still out
though right on whether involuntary
hospitalization is helpful to someone in
the short term or especially in the long
term because at some point they're
either hospitalized they could argue for
too long or they're maybe let go too
soon
well I would say one way to begin
thinking about that is what are the
Alternatives well the likely
alternatives are first of all just
leaving someone there in the street and
squalor and we know that people who are
homeless suffer all kinds of bad things
they die a few decades earlier than the
average American they're abused they're
victimized all kinds of terrible things
happen to them
um a very likely outcome is they wind up
in jail as we reduce the number of
people in Mental Hospitals over the
decade it looks like the number of
people in jail who have a serious mental
illness swell their now about a thousand
people in the New York City Jail system
who have a serious mental illness that's
much larger than any sum in any state
mental hospital left in New York so if
we are trying to clear a bar that's set
by jails for the streets or shelters
um you know I don't think that's an
impossibly high bar to clear
um and ultimately that's what the mayor
is trying to move towards
you've written the book literally on
homelessness in America recently this is
obviously a problem especially in other
big cities as well
do you envision this plan as something
that would translate in some of those
other cities something that they might
try as well getting more aggressive with
the mentally ill homeless population
well in principle yes every city to a
degree grapples with this problem
defined by the intersection of
homelessness and mental illness there's
the mental illness problem there's a
homelessness problem and they intersect
and lying at the intersection is this
cohort of the mayor is trying to do
something about certainly if you've ever
been to San Francisco's tenderloin
neighborhood or Los Angeles
um you know that this problem is not
unique to New York and it's an
exhausting problem it's a depressing
problem and despite enormous resources
that have been devoted to it
particularly New York and California a
lot of people are sort of inclined to
throw up their hands it just seems like
we can get nowhere with it so yeah if
New York City can get somewhere with it
that would I think be very encouraging
to jurisdictions
um elsewhere such as San Francisco and
Los Angeles
Adams in New York has faced some
significant pushback for this plan some
of it coming from the New York civil
liberties Union their executive director
saying he's playing fast and loose with
legal rights and not dedicating the
resources necessary to address the
mental health crises I guess the flip
side of that would be at least he's
trying I mean do you think that level of
criticism is warranted at this point
I think that the mayor knew he was
picking a fight with this I think that
he just thought that the status quo is
unacceptable that you know we we've been
doing a lot of the things that those
advocacy groups want for a long time
um and New York will continue to do that
but we really need to reassess our
attitude towards involuntary treatment
this will is going to require a
sustained push
um certainly uh throughout at least
throughout next legislative session in
Albany
um and the mayor is going to need a lot
of support
um and hopefully he's going to attract
more support but I think you know a lot
of people in the public are going to be
sympathetic to this because this is just
you know New Yorkers like why should
this be such a normal experience in New
York to just walk by somebody obviously
suffering and just sort of shrug your
shoulder saying well you know I guess
he's supposed to be there like what do
you want me to do what else could we
expect
so we he's trying to do something about
that the mayor's plan includes enhanced
police training and emphasizes a team
approach for handling someone in crisis
there's also a hotline for police to
call for help with decisions about
involuntary transport to a hospital
police right now they don't have a
direct path to what they have to do in
normal policing so now you're taking
them for the homeless situation Joe
Cardinale is a retired New York City
Police Lieutenant who says this will put
police in a more difficult situation
we've faced this before we've had
homeless issues before mayor Giuliani
approached it and did the same thing
this is a page out of his book if they
don't want to go take them by force if
you have to because it's for their good
all right but if we look at what's
happening on the streets of New York
right now with the homeless people and
with other people that aren't homeless
that are just shooting up on the streets
they're just living there they're
attacking people they're doing things
they have become a major detriment to
this city so we should have the right to
go in and take them in into protective
care not custody protective care get
them the physical help they need the
mental help they need get them the food
they need the nutrition give them a warm
bed to sleep in some of them are so
adverse they don't want to know anything
about these programs they just want to
be out on the street but what happens
when they find these people you know
dead on the side of an Avenue and people
are walking by them and you don't know
whether they're sleeping or anything you
need to get them to help I guess the
concern to with as you say some of the
people not really wanting help per se
the concern is always well does this
mean they could be end up
institutionalized you know forever
trying to transition back into some sort
of a quote-unquote normal life becomes a
factor
you know you have to feel for many of
these people are out there some of them
many of them are veterans all right so
the veterans have to you know the VA has
to get involved in this as well
these individuals have families some of
them don't many of them do many of their
families don't know where they are so if
you can identify who they are and where
they've been and what their intentions
are and try to put them in touch with
their family if you get one success
story out of 10 out of 20 it's good so
any program to get back to where we were
to help them and get them off the
streets is a good program it's just that
you have to fine-tune it without
government overstepping their bounds you
want to fine-tune it where the police
are comfortable doing their job saying
hey I could work with that I could do
that we had emergency psychological
training back in the day and it
continues to this day so the police
department does evolve with what's
happening in in our city today but it's
become a dangerous situation because so
many of these homeless individuals are
attacking people on the streets and that
I never saw that to the degree it is now
you saw it occasionally but not to the
degree it is now
is there a better solution to address
these I guess really dual issues of
homelessness and the portion of the
homeless population that commits crime
and it does have mental illness a better
solution than what the mayor is rolling
out
the mayor should know about this because
he's on both ends of the spectrum he was
a police officer he was you know a
supervisor and now he's the mayor what
he needs to do is bring the people that
know mental health the best into a
conference with the police department
sit down and say how can we make this
work and just get a form together and
say what do you think but this is what I
fear you cannot Ram it down the police
officer's throat this is what you have
to do they already took the Judgment
away from police officers when it comes
to policing on the street now you're
going to tell them this is the way this
has to be done and it goes against some
of their training what I'm saying is it
has to coincide with the training they
already have and add to that training
but when you stop winning mandates on
the police officers you will do this you
will not do this then they're just going
to sit by and say hey you know what
they're doing now there's no more
proactive policing and this comes on the
proactive policing I wondered if this is
a responsibility police and their
leadership
would want or not want or is it a
situation where they do want the chance
to do more
oh I think the police department would
step up to the uh to the challenge of
doing something about this absolutely
because it affects our city it affects
crime it affects definitely the quality
of life in the city is greatly affected
by this so you need to have them come up
with a plan where everybody's on board
and it's an effective plan you know many
of them aren't criminals a majority are
criminals they're just like I said some
of our veterans so we really need to
help them out no matter what and mental
illness has been put by the wayside for
way too long for the past three years
has been put on the back burner and this
is the residual effect from that so
people need to step up to the plate and
get them the mental health they need and
the physical hope they need they need to
be taken care of because the cold
weather is coming all right and and
that's another bed that's another bad
one I can be a killer too
um
former NYPD police Lieutenant Joe
Cardinale thank you so much for your
time oh anytime thank you for having me
[Music]
and now some good news with Tanya J
powers
a New York law enforcement officer is
getting a reputation as the baby
Whisperer after delivering an infant at
a home on Long Island Suffolk County
Sergeant John Eric Negron was one of a
group of officers who responded to a
woman who went into labor at her home
recently about 15 minutes after she'd
called 9-1-1 her new baby boy made his
appearance into the world Sergeant
Negron had known what to do because it
was not the first time he'd been pressed
into service with a home delivery in
2017 he responded when another baby
arrived unexpectedly at a Mount Sinai
home when he got there the baby wasn't
breathing so he sucked the fluid out of
the infant's Airway with a turkey baster
from the family's kitchen and the boy
took a breath the child's parents asked
Negron to be the baby's Godfather and he
accepted he now celebrates birthdays and
holidays with the family Negron doesn't
have any kids himself but he is also
assisted in other births during his
career he told Newsday that he keeps
expecting each time to be the last but
if this point he wouldn't be surprised
if it happened again in New York Tanya J
Powers Fox News
put the power of over 100 meteorologists
and the worldwide resources of fox in
your hands with the fox weather podcast
precise personal powerful subscribe and
listen now at foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts subscribe
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your Fox News commentary
what's on your mind when I was a kid
during the Christmas season one of my
neighbors had white lights all over
their property and their Christmas tree
just plain white lights
I didn't understand why anybody would
want boring white lights I like the
colored lights and I like them blinking
now as an adult
I like white lights I think they're very
nice very classy but my kids they like
the colored lights
so when Christmas season comes around we
have to negotiate a little bit
a little bit of the color a little bit
of the white lights
but no blinking that's where I draw the
line
and every year we buy a real Christmas
tree the debate is when do we get it
right after Thanksgiving or do we wait
until the middle of December
now when I was growing up we had a fake
tree
I liked it at the same time every year
we'd go up in the attic and we'd drag
the tree box down the stairs we'd take
the fake branches and spread them all
over the living room floor and would
organize them by size and they would
start to build the tree to the sounds of
the Andy Williams Christmas record
so real tree or fake tree which do you
like
these are the kind of debates that can
tear families apart
and when do you open your presents
Christmas Eve or Christmas morning
well the folks at Fox Nation thought we
better settle these debates once and for
all
so we put together what I think is the
most fun Christmas special ever the
great Christmas debate
we brought together some of the great
Fox News personalities Janice Dean Jerry
Willis Julie Banderas will Kane Jimmy
phela and Michael Loftus we had two
teams in front of a live audience
tackling the toughest questions of the
holidays it's streaming now on Fox
Nation and I hope you join us and
remember it's not about who wins or
loses it's about who brings the most
spirit
I'm Tom shallow
[Music]
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown now and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcast
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
from the Fox News podcasts Network FOX
News rewind financial crisis 08 a look
back at the biggest financial crisis
since the Great Depression the market is
not functioning properly subscribe now
at foxnewspodcasts.com